Hey there Fellow Scholars I am Károly Zsolnai-Fehér and this is Two Minute Papers,
where we learn that research is not
only for experts, it is for everyone.
Is everything going
fine? I hope you are all doing well and
you're having a wonderful time.
In this episode we're going to look at a
time-lapse videos
Let's say you would like to build a
beautiful time-lapse of a Norwegian glacier.
The solution sounds quite simple.
Just mine hundreds of photos from the
Internet and build a time-lapse video from them.
If we just cut a video from them where
we put them one after each other we will
see a disturbing flickering effect.
Why? because the images were taken at a
different time of the day
so the illumination of the landscape is
looking very different on all of them.
They are also taken at a different time
of the year and from different viewpoints.
Moreover, since these images are taken by cameras, different regions of the image
may be in-focus and out-of-focus.
The algorithm therefore would have to
somehow equalize all of the differences
between these images and bring them to a common denominator. This process we call
regularization and it is a really
difficult problem.
On the left you can see the flickering
effect from the output of a previous
algorithm that was already pretty good
at regularization but it still has quite
a bit of flickering. Here on the right
you see the most recent results from the
University of Washington and Google,
compared to this previous work.
The new algorithm is also able to show
us these beautiful rhythmical seasonal
changes in Lombard St., San Francisco.
It can also show us how sculptures
change over the years and I feel that
this example really shows the
possibilities of the algorithm. We can
observe effects around us that we would
normally not notice in our everyday life
simply because of the reason that they
happen too slowly.
And now here's the final time-lapse for the glacier that we were looking for.
So, building high-quality time-lapse
videos from an arbitrary set of
photographs is unbelievably difficult
and these guys have just nailed it.
I'm loving this piece of work! And, what do
you think?
Did you also like the results? Let me
know in the comments section. And for now,
thanks for watching and I'll see you
next time!